welcome to this meeting of the
mid-suffolk District Council planning
committee may I first remind you all of
some domestic Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and that your
laptops are switched to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
if you are intending to do so please
could you inform the committee Clerk
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
voting immediately via a far exit and
make your way to the assembly point at
Ipswich Town Football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
Forex sits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium the ground floor
area and the walkways if you are in the
atrium at the time of the alarm follow
the sign to the nearest fire exit use
the stairs not lifts
do not re-enter the building until told
it's safe to do so
so before we begin there's some
introductions
um we have the members who will be
making the decision on my right we have
the area planning manager Gemma Walker
we have the legal advisor Christine
flintner we have the case officer Bron
Curtis who will be presenting via teams
and we also have
um
Isaac
Stringer another planning officer to
support we have governance officers
Claire Philpot Mandy Smith and Alicia
Norman who are keeping the meeting on
track and we have award member James
Caston
um so can I move to the agenda
so item number one is apologies for
absence and substitutions do we have any
penny is substituting for councilor
Davies and councilor lay is substituting
for Council of Matheson thank you thank
you uh item number two to receive
Declarations of disclosable pecuniary
interests and other registerable or
non-registerable interests by members
are there any to declare
no
um item number three Declarations of
lobbying are there any to declare
I think we've all been lobbied by the uh
on the one case
um
Council a have you had any lobbying
emails
but I think the main members of the
committee and councilor Penny have
you've had them yeah I think we've all
been lobbied
uh item number four uh Declarations of
personal site visits we've all been on a
a organized site visit today we don't
need to declare that because that's not
a personal one has anyone been and
visited the site on their own any other
occasion
nope
uh so item number five
um
MPL 23 12 confirmation of the minutes of
the planning committee meeting held on
the 13th of September 2023.
um we have an amended version of the
minutes which are included in the tabled
papers
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of those minutes
um so could I please have a proposer to
accept those minutes councilor heading
and thank you and a secondary Council of
War boys thank you uh now I think we're
going to do this vote by show of hands
because we've got a couple of people
struggling with the mod.gov so we'll
just do a show of hand to accept them
that to approve the minutes of the
meeting
if you're for approving the meetings
minutes
so that looked like
um yes that's unanimous thank you um so
the minutes of the meeting have now been
confirmed and will be signed in due
course item number six uh to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with council's petition scheme
thank you
only got the one planning application
today
um DC
2104711 Land north of Thailand brownford
Suffolk and I will now invite the case
officer Bron Curtis to introduce the
application to the committee thank you
Ron
thank you chair good evening chair good
evening members I'll just run you
through your table papers to start with
because there's quite a lot of
information in there just to make sure
that you're happy with what you have
so starting on your page 16. you have a
joint local Plan update that's following
the publication of the inspectors report
that we received last week on the main
modifications
that those pages 16 to 19 also include
an updated description of the
development of this application which
clarifies the maximum capacity of the
development as 49.9 megawatts AC
and also an updated recommendation
which includes a new condition from the
recommendation that you are being asked
to consider last time
which
deals again with capacity and asks for
limits the capacity but also asks for
periodic submission of evidence to
demonstrate that the capacity generation
moving on then Pages 20 to 26
are an email trail of communications
between myself and a local resident
objector
and that is to do with um
in the first instance
Works being carried out on-site
um within within recent days and weeks
and also a second query about the
capacity
of the installation you can see my
various responses to those queries
then moving on to Pages 27 to 33 you can
see Communications between myself and
the applicant EDF
which add to that discussion to clarify
the capacity issue
and then moving on to page 34 there is a
statement on behalf of EDF by evershed
solicitors which deals with the capacity
issue
in a slightly more legal language
hopefully they all make sense
for you
um you've also got some plans which you
will have seen in um at this at the site
visit hopefully and I have in the
presentation so I'll run you through
that but do please stop me at any point
if you have a question
so I realize you've seen the slideshow
before and there's not a lot of
difference it's just some additional
plans which adds some context to some of
the issues that came up at the last
meeting so I won't spend a lot of time
but do let me know if you want me to go
backwards or forwards between slides
application site is land to the north of
Thailand the countryside close to the
Village of bramford
to give you the context on an Ordnance
base you can see the extensive
right-of-way Network a series of Highway
Network you can also see overhead lines
which you'll have seen on your site
visit this afternoon and you can also
see the bottom of the screen we just
change that pointer
table route which leads down to Bullen
lane and then to the National Grid
substation at the end of Bullen Lane
the application site in context with
planning constraints you can see the
areas of flood extent the areas of
designated SLA
special landscape area
and other rights of way
this plan shows the split of
agricultural land classification for the
purposes of best and most versatile land
your policy or current policy cl11
approximately half the site is grade 3A
which is BMV and the other half grade 3B
or non-agricultural which is not BMV for
the purposes of policy
block plan just showing the layout of
the Development Across the site
and there is an extract there showing an
elevation of the solar panels
this plan is included to show you the
relationship of the site which is shown
hatched on the right hand side here
relative to other developments that are
either granted or proposed and currently
under consideration in the immediate
area so you will also have seen on your
visit this afternoon part of the site
for the stackcraft development which is
on the southern side of Thailand and you
will also have seen part of the site for
the enso development which has planning
permission from both babe and
mid-suffolk
you may also have continued on to put in
Lane where you you could have seen the
National Grid substation
which this project would connect
Innovation view of solar panels
you will have seen the site to a
proposed site entrance from Thailand
leading as it does to an existing
agricultural pad and then grain store
this plan shows The Works to improve
that access and create an access
dedicated for the solar installation but
also the creation of passing Bays on
Thailand to improve
by way safety specifically for the
construction phase development
and then there are three passing Bays
proposed so this is a cropped plan just
to show you how they are staggered along
Thailand
back towards the b-trib one three
Lorraine way
mitigation planting proposals this is a
little bit more detail than you saw last
time just with some coloring to pick out
the detail of the planting belts close
to the Residential Properties so long
rods Farm Rutter scottishes Copenhagen
cottages and Thai view Cottage and I
have those in a bit more detail
hopefully you're able to get a sense of
when you're on site this afternoon
planting along the boundary there with
Rochester's Ross's Farm
around the southern edge of the boundary
with Copenhagen Cottage
and the proximity to Thai view Cottage
then you probably don't need to see
these because it will be fresh in your
mind actually what it was like on site
but just to take you very quickly
through the views of the site and some
of the views from the highway
if a general landscape
setting
and moving moving on to some wider
landscape setting images and some
visualization images
as well
so a reminder of the development is for
a renewable energy generation scheme the
expectation is that that would generate
the approximate electricity needs of
14th that's a typo I didn't change it
from last time sorry 14 and a half
thousand average homes
um and there's the carbon offset as well
uh we have had some questions last time
about grazing and grass and we have
confirmed with EDF that that is
um that is possible perfectly possible
to combine the two
and to have an agri-voltaics type
development
um and there might be some more
information on seed mix if you want to
get into detail of that
so I'll just remind you of the
recommendation you have in the report
and the advice from officers is to Grant
planning permission subject to
conditions to mitigate the various
impacts of the development not
to diminish the impacts of The Proposal
particularly in terms of landscape
impact we recognize that there would be
a significant adverse impact and a
significant change to the character of
the landscape in the area
um and that that would be a material
change particularly to the experience of
Rights of way users and Highway users
that there would be an impact on best
and most versatile land through the
removal of the the part of the site that
is BMV for the period of life of the
development
but that that development is time
limited and reversible and that there is
uh information to suggest that
development would result in an overall
betterment of the potential of the land
for food production for future
Generations
um and that the Heritage impact that
Rutter's Farm is a grade two listed
buildings the development does lie
within the setting of that listed
building
but that the conclusion of your officer
is that the um contribution of the
landscape setting to the significance of
the asset is uh not not so much as would
warrant more than a low level of of harm
and that that has been weighed in
accordance with the
um the balancing exercise required by
legislation
and that the public benefits of the
development being the renewable energy
generation and contribution to Net Zero
in a low carbon economy
are considered to outweigh that harm
and then on that point I have
um also to remind you of the
um the the underpinning
principle of making decisions on
planning applications the planning and
poultry Purchase Act which requires
consideration of whether a development
is in accordance with the development
plan when there's a whole
and that where our development is it
should be granted
um where it is not in accordance it
should not be granted unless there are
material considerations that indicate
otherwise so there's kind of two
elements to that and you'll see in the
assessment that I have said that
um there is
um a a good level of General accordance
with the plan Winward as a whole there
is some tension with the policies that
deal with best of most versatile land
and
um and landscape and visual impacts in
particular
but that there are more material
considerations that indicate that
planning permission should be granted
and I have given a rundown of what they
are in the report
um and that is what then justifies the
recommendation that you have which is
updated in your
um table papers on 18 and 19 Pages 18
and 19. thank you
uh thank you very much gron um uh do we
have any questions from members
councilor having them
thank you
um when is this
the game that my son plays that's is it
whatever it's called the Skycraft one
when is that coming on board
the application is submitted and it's
been through an initial round of
consultation
um the applicant has asked that we delay
uh determination of the application
because they want to make some design
changes I actually have a meeting with
them tomorrow
um to understand a bit more about what
those design changes might be and the
time frame for them to submit that
information that would then need to run
through a new round of publicity and
consultation to enable everybody to have
a look at that and to submit any amended
or additional comments before it was
written up and would come back to
committee
yeah you another question so it could be
you know in a matter of months like
three months Maybe
it's unlikely to be that quick
but
um
within the next six months is is more
likely
uh any other questions from members
councilor Elkin and then we'll have
councilor Penn
thank you chair
um we walked through this site this
afternoon and there were quite long
areas of footpath that were very open
and I think my understanding from the
from the papers is that the public
rights of way officer preferred that
rather than hedging to create narrow
corridors can I just check it is that
something that was
the pro offices recommendation was it
discussed with the
parish council at all just sort of yeah
I'm just curious about how how that
decision came about if you know know the
history of that one
tea Council have some fairly standard
guidance on how development like this
should relate to rights of way and how
rights of way should be
um to be protected and to ensure that
users can can maintain access through
development
um
what that says is that you should avoid
over in closing rights of way so you
should avoid tunneling but there's a
balance to be struck between
um the visual impact on rights of way
users and and that tunneling effect so
there wasn't any discussion with the
parish council about the mitigation
proposed but there was quite a bit of
communication between the applicant and
your landscape advisor so what you have
in your recommendation is that in
addition to the information that's
already submitted as mitigation
proposals for some planting along the
southern side of uh part of footpath
eight which is one of the footpaths that
you walked the one that goes east west
so that the um the development is
screened
from views from the right-of-way there
but not on the Northern side of that um
right away so it's not enclosed
did you all have another follow-up or
was that it
uh councilor Penny yeah I was going to
ask a different question but I'll ask a
follow-up question to that one I mean
um so were planting to take place on the
Northern side but only on one side of
the footpath
um
I I believe that that wouldn't amount to
a tunneling effect
would there be scope for that
as far as
um that is outside the red line site
boundary but I believe May well be in
the control of the applicant or maybe
capable of being in the control of the
applicant but
um
it it would depend
how much planting to what extent and
whether that was together with the
planting on the southern side as to
whether that would be something that the
rights of way team and the landscape
officer would encourage so it might be
something we would have to take away and
discuss with those parties and for the
committee to delegate that to officers
to reach a position of mutual agreement
between those parties rather than
dictating perhaps where planting should
go
at this stage
does that answer your question or do you
have something do you have another
another query
I don't know how to phrase it as a
question but um I was thinking
the the fencing
um is not particularly sightly it's
uh particularly where it's near prop
properties it creates an impression
I'm trying to avoid using the word a
prison-like
um
impression and
do you think hedging or substantial
Wildlife Corridor would might be prefer
preferable in those areas
so
the fencing that is proposed I have a
photograph oh it's on screen at the
moment that's the sort of thing so
stockproof fencing that is something
that could be erected on the land now
without the need for planning permission
so that's the first thing to say just to
just to give the context of that and
that that sort of enclosure is not
uncommon for certain agriculture
operations just to deal with
um deer and other wildlife
but in terms of
the
Outlook from Individual properties
we have the plans that I showed you a
little earlier on in the
presentation let me just pop back to
them so the proposal is for some
planting belts which
respond to that
respond to the Views the the dominant
views of the development from the
properties it's also worth bearing in
mind that there is no right to a view in
planning so that is not a material
consideration that a person's view of a
thing but Outlook is a different a
different thing and that is an amenity
issue so the the two are can be
difficult to distinguish but it is the
sense of enjoyment of one's property
and whether that is dominated by a
particular
thing within a within the view of you
enjoying your own property so the
applicant has included the planting
belts
to to mitigate the the visual impact
along those in particular those three
groups of properties
thank you I'm sure we'll we'll discuss
um the benefits or disbenefits of
planting when we come to debate
cancer hardingham you have a question
point of information
um which is for path eight
I know I should be aware of
exactly I'll just show you on the plan
footpath eight is the one that goes
wrong let me show you a plan that's
so it's this one that goes from
Copenhagen Cottage and then it comes
out towards Thai view Cottage let me
just show you a wider
so sorry I've not got the right pointer
on am I bronze can you make that full
screen
yeah sorry
I think it's the football there we
walked on from Copenhagen Cottage to
Thai green
that's right it's that one let me just
change this pointer sorry
it's that one that goes east west and
you took it up around Copenhagen Cottage
here and you will have gone to Thai view
Cottage there
so the landscape of the devices in
addition to the planting already
proposed for some planting along
along the site boundary on the southern
edge of footpath eight
is there
thank you any further questions of the
officer
uh councilor penny
the the question I was going to ask was
the
um in connection with the correspondence
in the table papers
about the the capacity of the site
and it is mentioned that uh the output
would be capped
um
is there
an implication might be that this the
the size of the site is larger than it
needs to be to
um create these
67.5 megawatt output or is that
something I should ask to the developer
um developer May well be able to give
you more of a explanation as to the
technology and equipment that they're
installing and why they need what they
need in order to achieve the capacity
but um the chair may also be able to
give you some Physics on the way that
Peak capacity for installed capacity
translate to actual generation
capability and how you get transmission
losses when you are converting from DC
to AC and various other things
sorry
and the physics
uh Council of War boys
yep uh thank you uh do you have some
more information about the um containers
which have been used for I believe for
the inverters I think I've identified
them the the little uh black rectangles
but there's four of them
along the section I Believe by Rutter's
Farm
can you confirm that and what color are
they going to be are they bare metal
black or Orange
I might have to come back up to you in
that if that's okay please
yeah I think
is tea oh yes I think there's a little
rectangles on the sort of access track
there's like a little turning
um hammerheads and a little gray
rectangles that I think those are the
I think they're containers are they
did that help with the pointers
so you've got I think counselor were you
asking what color they were going to be
yes
um I'll I'll come back on the color I
don't have I'm the applicant May well be
able to tell tell me off the top of the
head but I don't have that handy but I
can find it out from the submission
documents there's quite a lot of them
and I think they're going to be as much
of an impact as
other items
okay well maybe we can ask the applicant
about the um containers are there any
further questions from members
if not I will now invite the public
speakers to address the committee
so I think first we have uh Caroline
Walton from bramford Parish Council and
you will have your three minutes
uh so if you press the button on the mic
when you're ready and I will use my
high-tech timer thank you thank you very
much Brantford Parish Council was
delighted that at the last meeting you
made the important decision to visit the
site for the EDF proposal we hope that
seeing it for yourselves you now have a
greater understanding of our reasons for
objecting to this application and ask
you support us and refusing it here
today we hope your visit answered lots
of your questions but mostly we hope it
is making you ask more
stand that we
that with the show this application is
generating 70 megawatts of solar power
and not below the 50 megawatts threshold
which allows it to go through
mid-suffolk as the LPA is it for you to
decide its outcome we have concerns that
the planning officer continues to
justify this application being decided
here when evidence shows it is an nzip
you must decide if this is correct we
challenge this information but we have
evidence from the National Grid saying
it is registered on the Tec register at
57 megawatts
we must protect our landscape you've
seen the rising land from the village if
developed will be highly visible from
both locally and Ipswich your landscape
officer stated that there would be
significant landscape harm and proposed
screening was inadequate which you've
all seen today with vast borders of the
development with no planting or
sympathetic screening proposed and lost
views
you've seen the site engulf little Sage
Caravan site and Copenhagen Cottage with
little screening provided this business
that sells itself on Rural identity is
under threat you visited properties
including grade 2 listed also bordering
on the development that have been given
little screening with panels within
meters of their boundary
this application is more than double the
size of Enzo application recently passed
at appeal the 210 Acres of agricultural
land which at least 50 percent is grade
3A class best and most versatile must be
protected and used for growing our food
to reduce importing and provide jobs for
our local farmers
agricultural production would cease
completely on this land as EDF are
asking for change of land use in this
application title there is no plan for
sheep grazing and panels are too low for
such as sheep would cause severe damage
to them
the protected Skylark nesting seem to be
addressed by the developer with mention
of mitigation your own ecology officer
has a holding objection due to the
threat of this protected species so it
is essential this is completed the
single Track Road of Thailand which you
experience today with its Quiet Lane
status I hope you agree is inappropriate
access to the solar farm and unsafe for
the users of such a road this is a
national cycle route has no pavement
consists of blind bends and hills and is
regularly used by equestrians
impact is overwhelming for Brantford and
its surrounding communities 210 acres
here 86 acres by Enzo and 122 by
stratcraft all solar facilities adjacent
to each other is over development there
is no exceptional reason for this
development just because these fields
are close to the substation making it
more cost effective for the developer
does not make it the right location for
a solar farm we must acknowledge the
Major Impact these projects have on our
local environment and ensure that
sustainable energy does not come at any
cost but must placed in an appropriate
location with less impact on our
community thanks thank you just over the
three minutes I thought that sounded
like your last sentence I like to carry
on thank you very much do we have any
questions of the parish council
counselor okay
thank you
um
books along the very open track today I
think it was footpath eight
um that I was a little bit confused when
Bob was speaking that there was mention
of some hedging when we were all there
this afternoon my understanding was that
there most of that doesn't have hedging
at the moment and it will have uh solar
panels coming fairly close up either
side
um in terms of sort of community views
the public rates away officer would
prefer there not to be a tunneling
effect I need to have an open view over
the fields I don't know if you feel able
to speak on behalf of the community
if your view of fields is now a view of
solar Farms would large Hedges and a
tunneling effect be preferable
it is a difficult question and I think
most Fields the different views you have
different feelings on it I think the
the we as a parish council feel it
softens
the appearance of the panels is going to
be a long time until those Hedges are
tall enough they say they're going to
grow into three meters so that's that's
a lot of years growth so it does soften
um on that footpath eight we walk today
as we were walking the right side by
Copenhagen is obviously not in the plan
the left is and I think planting on that
left side is essential because you can't
view across there because it's on Higher
Ground anyway but it does then make it
quite a tower but um there are lots of
places where planting could be improved
we'd like to see some on the entrance to
Copenhagen on that track to avoid that
just being fencing and then panels it's
not a very nice greeting for the people
who are coming for a holiday and the
residents there so I think there's lots
of planting that could be improved and I
would
very much like the parish council to
have an input on that because we have a
tree Ward and we do have we pride
ourselves in making sure with our
applications that we decide on native
tree species things that are good for
the environment things that are local so
we would very much welcome to be
involved in the planting but I do think
the planting in lots of areas needs to
be better and improved
thank you thanks for
thanks thank you
um has anyone else got a question
councilor penny
yeah just just to follow follow up on
that would um in your opinion would
would the community like to be involved
in um
not only deciding what is planted but
perhaps
helping to uh
Maine Maine
maintain it and care for their
I couldn't comment on maintaining
because that obviously comes at a cost
but certainly we are a community who
involve the school and the scouts and
people like that in planting and so we
could make it a community event and
things like that is a possibility but um
maintaining might be difficult because
that all costs I just happen to notice
the horticultural supplies at Rutter
Farm I don't know if there's a local
um enthusiasm for um
certainly the community is very keen
gardeners and enjoy the outdoors but um
I don't know that Horticultural business
sadly has come to an end and is is
currently closing so they will be there
no more but
certainly we support planting
um if there are any other questions I
I'd just like to ask the officer a
question which was brought to mind by by
what what Caroline Walton was talking
about the Skylark mitigation which there
is a holding objection now whilst we're
on the site visit this afternoon we were
told about I think it was like a sort of
triangular field just to the north along
summersham road which was going to be
used for the Skylight mitigation I think
that might have been the applicant
talking about it has that been agreed
yet
um or not or is there still some dispute
about whether this efficient Skylight
mitigation thank you
it's been agreed in principle the your
um ecology officer and the ecologist
representing the applicant are just
discussing the detail of how that would
be delivered but the suite of conditions
I have already had a recommendation of a
suite of conditions from your ecologist
should we be minded to Grant permission
but you'll see that the recommendation
is still a deferral to resolve that
issue before we actually issue a
decision
but it is sort of that they're reaching
some sort of agreement at the moment
they are yeah yeah thank you
are there any further questions
uh okay so we now have an objection an
objector
um and Raymond um if you would like to
press the button on the microphone and
you will have your three minutes thank
you very much
in the hundred comments on the planning
portal none of which supported the
application the local community have
told you the impact we all believe the
scheme will have on our amenity our
valued Landscapes our public rights of
way our rural lands Our Heritage assets
and our lives
now you have seen the site for
yourselves could we perhaps remind you
of the policies you could use to refuse
this application
to protect the landscape policies cl3
E10 and FC 1.1 seek to maintain and
enhance the landscape your landscape
officer said there would be significant
landscape harm
your public rights of way officer said
the impacts in terms of views and
experience will be ex will be
significant
to protect agricultural land which is
more than 50 percent best and most
versatile you have policy cl-11 CL 17
E10 there are 85 hectares of prime food
producing land being taken out of
agricultural use
protect the setting of Rutter's
Farmhouse a grade 2 listed building you
have policy hb1
these fields once belong to the farm and
were part of a much larger brownford
Hall estate which had huge influences in
the local area seen even to this day
your heritage officer said there would
be Heritage harm
policy cl8 seeks to refuse permission
that threatens protected species your
ecology officer has outstanding concerns
for Skylark habitat
if you think the use of Thailand with
Quiet Lane status for large numbers of
hgvs is unsafe for other users
or you think that there would be unsafe
access or egress for any users of the
access track also a public right-of-way
you could use policy T10 and policy E10
your highways officer said he wasn't
happy about the use of Thailand so did
the contractor group attack already on
site
the impact on little Sage Hill campsite
and on residence some may be interested
in visiting a solar farm for engineering
curiosity but trying to rest and relax
and live next to noisy inverters from
dawn to dusk for 35 years probably not
age 16 seeks to protect the immunity of
existing residential areas so there's
nine policies of the existing plan you
could use and from the emerging joint
local plan this LP 13 15 16 17 18 19 24
and 27 all supported by the nppf
including paragraph 187 which seeks to
protect existing businesses from harm
from new development
this EDF site is more than double the
size of the recent Enzo appeal site the
cumulative impact of energy
infrastructure in this area is already
massive please don't give us more are
you on your final I am we ask you to
refuse this application thank you thank
you very much
um do we have any questions of the
objector
okay thank you very much
um I now call Martin crack uh who is
going to speak as a supporter
um you two um have your three minutes if
you press the button on the microphone
thank you very much yeah thank you thank
you chairman and thank you for the
opportunity to speak tonight
and I can assure you that I do
understand local concerns and then I'm
not a person who doesn't care about the
areas that I farm
I've been farming in southwark for 44
years and I've owned Thailand since
2000.
so I have 23 years of experience of the
land in question
I've been astonished and somewhat
bemused by the comments relating to the
productivity of the land from objectives
as as far as I'm aware I'm the only
person who actually owns the land and
farm to land along with my Pharma
contractors
we are the only people who has who have
the knowledge of the
productivity of this land
I can assure you that the land is
average at Best in terms of crop
production regardless of 3A or 3B this
is not prime agriculture land and it's
not as productive as other land uh as
that I farm
I farm in Thailand with Partnership of a
local farmer family
I've kept them fully aware of the solar
plants and they understand our reasons
for pursuing the project
farming is increasingly difficult
emphasized by recent world events I'm
sure we all know about that
and I need to do diversify to keep my
overall farming business as afloat and
strong for the future
the solar farm from our perspective
would help me to do that
to invest in new machinery and
infrastructure on the remaining land I
have
it would be something that would provide
me with much needed additional income to
support my business
and without a I do have genuine concerns
for the future
I have chosen to let the land to be
developed because it isn't the best
farmland
then this agricultural land go for solar
will help to ensure the future of my
farming business
I was approached and have been
approached by a number of renewable
energy companies at so for solar at toy
Lane
and I decided to go with EDF because
they have a great connection and I
thought that they could do the best job
including consideration for the local
community
thank you
do we have any questions of Mr crack
thank you very much I now call on the
applicant Darren you two have
your three minutes uh you might just
have to wait till the
um time has passed through otherwise you
won't won't get you full time I'm afraid
um I can't make it go any quicker
okay so you're uh you're okay
um if you'd like to begin now thank you
thanks Chet and and uh thanks for uh the
opportunity to go on the site visit
today
uh we believe our application has been
well prepared and we have responded to
every request from from the officer this
is including working closely to achieve
the recommendation that is before you
today examples of this include the
archaeological trenching which has led
to the County Council withdrawing our
objection on cultural heritage grounds
we've talked about the Skylark
mitigation areas which we've agreed to
which is keeping the ecologist on board
and also we're improving Thailand for
Access including the provision of
passing bays and increased visibility at
the site entrance ensuring the county
highways feel that we can use Thailand
safely
it's been quite a long road of working
with your Cons with our local
Consultants your officers and advisors
to get to this point please be assured
that the application has been looked
over in great detail and every possible
mitigation incorporated into the scheme
EDF renew evf renewals believe as do
your officers that Thailand strikes a
right balance between the environmental
impacts and the need for low carbon
generation there are no perfect sites
out there they all have impacts and
Thailand is no different to that
our site is not in a special landscape
area and where there isn't an actual
screening we are proposing a robust
Landscaping plan
during the consultation process we've
moved panels away from Gardens and
provided buffer distances with
additional planting we are proud to
carry out additional planting and
provide temporary screening to ensure
that this is in place from day one
obviously there's been a lot of talk
about impact on agricultural land and
the overall impact of Thailand locally
is minimal and nationally in order to
meet the UK's solar Ambitions this will
mean a maximum of 0.5 percent of land
use for farming will be impacted this
will be less than the land is used for
golf courses
to help ensure that the project is built
safely we will set up a community
liaison group to ensure local people
know what is going to happen
Our Community Fund will provide over 700
000 pounds to be spent on local good
causes throughout the life of the
project we commit to this on every solar
farm we develop
mid-suffolk council is part of the
Suffolk climate change partnership which
declared a climate emergency in 2019
aiming to make suffer carbon neutral by
20 30. Thailand will help deliver those
Ambitions by being a shovel ready site
should permission be granted today and
start generating clean low carbon energy
by 2025. this will provide enough energy
for 14 and a half thousand Suffolk homes
and save 17 100 tons of carbon emissions
per year
I really wish I could say there are
solar Farms out there that don't have
impacts on local communities who live
near them but that wouldn't be true we
need to balance that and one thing I can
commit to is it will build out project
to the council requirements and provide
benefits and the mitigations which say
we will thank you chair
uh thank you very much maybe you could
um just answer the question about the
um inverter
containers we've been asked about what
color they're going to be and I'd also
like to know a little bit about the
noise that they might or might not
produce so maybe you could just explain
um what they're going to look like and
how much noise is likely to come from
them thank you yeah thanks Jack in terms
of the the containers that house the
inverters they can be any color that is
that that the council deem appropriate
and I believe under the planning
conditions we would have to submit um a
color scheme for those it can be green
or or any color that that is is you know
best for integration into the landscape
obviously we've designed the scheme so
that those inverter units are away from
Residential Properties there aren't any
longer backup from Rutter's Farm they're
well into the site as well as Copenhagen
Cottage and I believe your environmental
health officer is happy with with the
noise to be created from those
okay um
any further questions of the applicant
uh councilor Penny then Council
hardingham and councilor Elkin yeah
could I just uh get some clarification
on why
um
propose site needs needs to be the scale
that it is posed
clearly we're trying to maximize you
know the the you know the green
generation from our site and we have
looked at our scheme you know in terms
of scale and and in terms of offsets
from from properties and you know
ecological
um buffers and and
um zones that we need to keep away from
and obviously we do have a connection at
the Brantford substation which we you
know need to seek to utilize and just to
confirm that will that is a maximum of
of 49.9 megawatts not anything above
that we're fully aware of the the nsip
guidelines and and how that needs to be
adhered to the inverters are restricted
to that 49.9 megawatts and you know that
city is seeking to generate as you know
the maximum amount of renewable energy
from outside counselor
counselor
right thank you and if I could just
return to the capacity of the the site
in megawatts you state that it's in
paragraph two two
um that you're going to generate 67.5
000 megawatt hours per year
um now my experience with solar panels
um 10 years experience
suggests that you would
there is no chance that you're going to
make any significant Improvement on 900
kilowatt hours per kilowatt installed
per annum
which would mean that 67 and a half
thousand
megawatt hours per year is equivalent to
75 megawatts installed
could you
clarify that one for me please
uh yeah through through the chat in
terms of that that predicted output that
is based on our energy yield analysis
has carried out that in terms of the you
know the irradiation in the area
um in terms of you know the capacity
Factor these panels are called what's
called bifacial so they they attract you
know they generate from both sides not
just one side of the panel so so the
more efficient than say panels that are
on on roofs of buildings and so the
technology is probably advanced over a
number of years we're comfortable with
you know with those Figures it's not we
don't feel it's an overestimation and
councilor I can assure you the the
49.9 megawatts that will be the
inverters will convert from DC power
will be 49.9 megawatts
um and if I could just follow up on that
one
um the government estimate that I the
best estimate I've been able to find is
that your CO2 um
savings
um would be 0.223 of a kilogram of CO2
per kilowatt hour generated
which means that your 67.5
would be equivalent to 15 Tons of CO2
per annum and not 17 as you state it
just seems that you know um
an inconsistency there which I think you
seem to be exaggerating but what the
savings might be
Jeff I can just respond to that yeah I
in terms of those numbers councilor they
are based on the average that provided
by the UK government so so we're not
over again you know we believe and on on
the generation from that site that it
would you know the number of homes will
be 14 and a half thousand and the the
carbon savings will be 17 100 tons a
year and that you know we're very clear
about this Council we're not trying to
over egg anything there in terms of
those numbers We Believe those are based
on on one the actual energy predictions
from the sites using the panels that
we'll be using and secondly on
government numbers that we should do to
make sure we're consistent across you
know all our sites and and with the
industry
thank you
is that okay yeah councilor Elkin
um could you tell me how big the gaps
are between between the rows of panels
roughly
in terms of the the spacings can can
change but it's it's so around about
four to seven meters in certain
locations
to the farmer what he puts in his in his
field but
um if something like the rural payments
agency was okay with those wide rows
being planted with something like AB8
grass seed with flour Rich that's that's
flower rich
and the farmer claiming
um you know the additional payments for
that would that be acceptable does it
cause any access problems for example
because it has to be left to grow long
until the Autumn or would that
work done with solar panels if the RPA
was okay with that sort of use I mean
again through through the chat we're
more than happy to as I said through the
the detail to be agreed as part of this
application through the proposed
condition relating to the um the
Landscape Management plan and the
biodiversity Improvement plan and if
that you know that we can plant you know
a lot of the site with you know
something if it's compatible with and
the farmer can you know take some you
know some rural payments from that then
we're more than happy to do that uh
cancer and as I say you know there's a
lot of detail to be agreed and I did
give your your office a draft example of
of a of a landscape Improvement plan
which included a lot of detail around
what we'd actually plan on the site and
how we plant it so I think that is
something that we'd be more than happy
to to talk about through and agree
through a condition
it was more a technical question because
obviously with ABA you have to leave it
to grow long
you ever need you know to get Machinery
down the middle or anything like that
would you be just happy with you know
knee-deep grass between the solar panels
these these these sites don't need a lot
of Maintenance the panels do probably
need cleaning you know once a year
um and probably the grass will need
cutting once a year so so that's the
point when it's not heavily heavily
manicured you know areas of land it is
left for biodiversity Improvement
I mean it's I don't think we can
condition what the farmer puts in his
own field but just in terms of it having
a significant impact for biodiversity
then it might be something we can talk
about later
thank you
um could I just ask a question
the site visit was was extremely helpful
uh because you put some bits of fence
and some marker posts about where your
panels were going to come up to where
they were around the residential
buildings and yet when I look at the
plan
that it's the plan the same as those you
know that that distance you told us it
was going to be from the Rutgers when we
first got off the bus and looked near
Rutter's Cottages it looked like quite a
long way away from that edge and then I
look at the plan and it looks like
you've got your blue lines where your
panels are going to go right up to the
five meter hedge you're planning
um and can we be assured that that
although we've got blue lines on the
plans
we you are going to have that that
distance from those Residential
Properties because it doesn't look
obvious from the plan
maybe are the plans accurately scaled as
to where the panels are going to be is
what I'm really trying to say so again
chat you know in terms of where you know
we we're more than happy you know where
we put those indications today is where
the panels will be and whether this can
be controlled by a planning condition
that we've agreed the exact final layout
of the scheme before we we go ahead
we're more than happy to do that to make
sure we we commit to what you've seen
today
okay
uh councilor Penny did I see your hand
going up again
yes thank you chair
um just a question about Thai Lane
um out outside the six six to 12 months
of the construction phase
um how how much additional traffic would
would be generated by the site
thereafter
very little traffic uh Council would
would come during the operational phase
as I said there will be times where you
know items of equipment may need me may
need fixing but but generally you may
see you may see a Transit van once you
know once a week at most
so very very little traffic Association
you know there may be an annual service
then that requires you know the you know
the panels need to be cleaned you know
but that is you know very little traffic
and you know you're not talking you know
massive amounts of you know staff or or
contractors coming in at the during the
operational phase
okay uh Poor Boys did I see your hand go
up over there
yeah
yes um I'm not sure how much discussion
there has been between you and the Paris
Council but and one of the things that's
being said that there is seemed to be a
need for further landscape
mitigation along some of the footpaths
in particular which became very aware of
in the visit this afternoon
um
and
you mentioned rural
payments I
I am a little bit curious as to how that
the immediate Community will benefit
from this scheme or are there any
benefits you can offer to them
job if I can again chat look Council I
mean obviously we have proposed an
indicative Landscaping plan at the
moment with Hedges if you know and this
is uh you know sort of a commitment from
from EDF Renewables if there is more
plants in need along those those
footpaths in in areas around the
Residential Properties we're more than
happy to do that through the planning
condition and involve the parish council
and those residents in those discussions
on on those plans so so you know we have
provided an indicative plan but that as
I say is indicative and we're more than
prepared if the council and and the
parish council want that improved beefed
up what call it whatever you want we're
more than prepared to do that
and in terms of the maintenance of of
the Landscaping you know the trees
Hedges
um Wildflower sort of Meadows
it's difficult to get communities
involved in that but you know if we can
if there is such a you know local you
know
um body that can do that on our behalf
you know we would you know we would have
to pay for that maintenance anyway and
if there is a local body that can do
that that's set up
then we're more than you know prepared
to provide and they can do that work you
know work with that organization
okay thank you and Chad was there
another comment about the with you on
about the Community Fund councilor yes
yes so so that is set up on an annual
basis of 20 000 pound per annum which is
700 000 over the life of the project
index linked we EDF do that on all our
projects and there is a local body setup
panel
um that will involve the parish council
local councilors and you know other
members of the community decide how that
money spent and EDF you know make sure
that it's a community decide how that
money is spent
and that's index linked indexing
okay
um
yes
yes thank you I just um wanted to make
it clear that that wouldn't be a section
106 payment that's not something that's
considered still compliant so it's not
really a material consideration it's
something that's you're getting through
information here but from I think that's
it's right to point out that you mustn't
take that into consideration as material
in your planning judgment but it is a
standard practice okay if you just
wanted to make that clear
thank you
if there are no further questions of the
applicant I now call on the ward member
councilor James custom thank you
thank you very much Madam chairman and
um I'd like to thank all you and the
members of the planning committee to for
coming and visiting the ward today and
it's um it's really good to have you
there and just seeing exactly what we're
looking at
um
just before
um this meeting I was passed over a
resident passed me over something to um
a question something they wanted to
point out and I'll just read that before
I am start talking if that's okay
um the construction traffic management
plan in table 8.2 plans for an average
of three movements per hour between nine
and three PM over a six month period it
doesn't give a maximum figure and also
it doesn't allow for the um the um
actual Personnel that will arrive on
site so I think um when we can I I
teaching other people's
sort of letters my my apologies but
personally I think that um we do need to
look at the construction management the
construction management plan I think is
is conditioned
um anyway I don't I don't I don't think
we've got any facts about the conduction
construction management plan at the
moment have we anyone it's a draft
there's a draft construction management
plan is there but there hasn't yet been
agreed
just might need to check that with Bron
but yeah I'm pretty sure I had a
condition on and we'll be looking to
finalize the details through that
condition essentially
thank you um so that I think the
construction management plan will be
determined after today what the final
details are that whatever you've got to
draft
um
so maybe the comments can go in um
in writing because I can't take in all
those numbers anyway thank you thank you
chair and yeah I'll um I'll make sure
that happens
um it it is a um a query on it
um
so um yeah you've you've been to the
site now and I think um you can you can
see the impact and how um how dense and
intense the site is for um for renewable
energy the um
the um the impact and um on that
footpath area the um Copenhagen Cottage
and all around there the views from the
road is absolutely enormous the um it
seems like it's there's so many solar
panels crammed on this site that seems
to be very little other mitigation I've
looked at several solar um applications
recently and it does tend it does tend
to be a lot more mitigation on the
um there's a five meter area of wood
down the side I just I don't really know
what good if I I know probably some good
but not a huge amount of good a five
meter area of Woodland is the um
The Wildflower areas are are fantastic
but they're not anywhere that people can
benefit from them they're tucked away
behind Hedges the um
in my view the um
the area beside him rata's Cottage the
small area
um is not necessary
um it's a very small area and it has a
massive impact and we did we did have a
discussion about whether that could be
dropped out and I think that's something
I'd like to see the planning committee
and look into it's it's a very small
area with a massive area of um impact
but I'd rather you didn't approve
any of this I think this is in the wrong
place the um
I think the um
the um the level of solar on the site is
the absolute maximum it could be the
impact on the um the um campsite
is absolutely as big as it can be we
talk about not having tunneling all that
up there will be tunneled there will
only be solar panels and
um Sky there's not going to be anything
else all that view will be completely
gone I did go through this appeal and
had a look at um
some of the um rulings of the um
inspector on there and I'd just like to
share with you um
a few of the the bits that I did mention
the last time I spoke the um
the
um
paragraph 36 it says that the um impact
is low of the Enzo sailor farm this is
because on the basis that some views are
being filtered against the backdrop
provided by Woodland and existing
transmission pylons the um there's very
little of that going on on this site The
Wider Farm landscape this is paragraph
39 The Wider Farm landscape character
would Prevail and would not appear to be
industrial Beyond establishment
of the large pylons there's there's a
huge amount of industrialization all
down from one end of Thailand to the
next down um down at the start of
summersham road it's it's a massive
industrialization of the site but the
really important one I think that he
says here is a paragraph 63. concerns
have been raised in terms of the impact
of the proposed and of The Proposal on
local tourism the this includes the
nearby campsite and and the term in
terms of there's a very small campsite
on the um on the Enzo site it but it
says however in
for relations of well-being it's a very
small the Enzo site was very small but
this is absolutely massive we've walked
across it we it it took a long time from
walk to walk from one side to the other
I I'm not saying that sailor couldn't be
done successfully on this site but I
think the scale of this is just way too
high is is too big so um
I do think that this would stand up to
appeal I do think that you don't that
you that policies Don't force you to
approve this and um I am I ask you to um
refuse this plan application thank you
very much
thank you uh are there any questions of
councilor Caston
okay
um thank you so I now open this item Up
For Debate
is there anybody who would like to make
a start
having them
thanks very much
um
you know I'd like to say this is a
tricky one but but I have to say like I
did last time I don't I don't like it I
think it is I think it's unacceptable
really I think the impact is going to be
too much I think that the screening
they've done is is the absolute minimum
they can do I think they're taking it
back from The Quiet Road could be done I
think like cancer said that corner there
by Rutter's Cottages could be scrapped I
think that they I think they could do
more and um and I'm not at all happy
with this and that's my starting
thoughts
thank you uh anyone else wish to
um
say anything councilor Penny I'd like to
follow lavinia's point I think I'd
contrary to I can't know which speaker
mentioned perhaps James just now thought
that uh a three or five meter planting
Corridor wasn't that substantial like I
personally think a five meter
planting Corridor does allow for
um
a reasonable wild wildlife Corridor but
it they need to be connected and
extensive
thank you
anyone else wish to say anything
counselor holding them
follow up on the planting the agent
um
mentioned that the five meter page to
the north of Rutter's Cottage
was going to be a two row
planting and I would have thought that
you'd need an awful lot more than two
rows in order to make a five meter wide
Edge in a reasonable length of time
and from a wildlife point of view I
would think that five meters is
is helpful as a corridor for wildlife
but wider would be better
and i would support
what councilor hadima said about
mitigation and planting being
um
inadequate and I would like to see an
awful lot more planting around the site
and particularly up the Axis track to
Copenhagen cottage which I think is left
very bare and industrial on both sides
would be an unpleasant experience for
the people who who live and visit there
thank you
um
no one else seems to be leaping at the
bit so I I find this a very difficult
decision to make
um it it is large
um
it seems like a very large solar farm
um I I'm in a bit of two minds about the
planting
um because
at that footpath eight that we walked
along is is very wide and open you know
typical large Suffolk Sky scenery
and
I'm a bit concerned that if there's
planting on both sides of it it will
feel terribly enclosed but I don't know
what having a load of solar panels
either side of it
um even if they are set back I don't
know if that will also make it feel
enclosed in which case maybe trees are
better
so I I I'm into my and when we came to
that bit where the trees are on one side
of the path on the Northern side of the
path it just sort of completely
different character of a path so
whatever happens on this site whether we
put more planting on or we don't or we
don't have any I mean if there are solar
panels on there it will have an enormous
impact on the footpaths the views of the
countryside whether or not there's
planting it will make it totally
different I'm not denying that there
will be an impact but we have to assess
that impact on on all those that energy
being generated for 35 years and then we
have a better more biodiverse more
um fertile land underneath and I think
that is the that is the big dilemma is
it is there's no way it's not impacting
anybody it's certainly having a huge
impact but is that impact
acceptable
if we have a benefit from it and that's
what I'm
telling myself about apart trying to
work out if if we can mitigate that
impact
and say yeah okay there is an impact but
we're getting all that
solar energy which is going to power 14
000 homes or whatever it was
um there is a benefit but there's also
an impact and I don't think I really
know whether it's going to be look you
know whether it's I know I know you
don't people don't like change but
you know we don't like the look of
pylons but because hundreds of pylons
over that field and and your most sort
of
they blend in with a landscape now I'm
not saying that this enormous solar farm
is going to blend in with the landscape
tomorrow but
um maybe there'll be a time when we
accept looking at solar panels on fields
because all the rest of the Industrial
um work that's done in this country
since the Industrial Revolution you know
part of it is now part of our heritage
so you know I I really am in into mind
and I don't know
um which way to go but I I think if if
if we are going along the officer's
recommendation and we want to do
something about the planting I think we
need to tread very carefully and make
sure that we fully Engage The Parish
Council as well as the landscape people
to make sure that whatever planting gets
put on there is what the parish field is
appropriate because I think they're the
people on the ground who know what what
it's like so I wouldn't want to dictate
you've got to put more Hedges on I think
we need if we are going to dictate we
dictate that you talk to the parish
council and ask them what what sort of
hedging and what sort of planting they
would like but I'll see what other
people have got to say
um
because he hasn't said anything yet
yes I'm going to take your remarks a
little bit chair as well I mean I too
I can't argue this is a large solar farm
it does have we'll have a visual impact
I think
the
what's it there is a present in terms of
mitigation along Thailand and
[Music]
um
and the I mean we've talked about five
meters I I understood from the visit
this afternoon it was going to be 30
meters behind Rutter's Farm
you know which is is almost a small
small Compass really and
I agree completely that whatever
additional landscape mitigation there is
there should be a three-quarter
discussion there including the parish
council and and to follow up on their
wishes
um
standing there this afternoon I in
whichever direction you looked it was
impossible to see the the impact of man
on that that landscape and it's not a
natural landscape by any means it's been
farmed it's been hedge drugs torn up
there's been hedgerows put back
um
and
the the context in which we need
um
solar energy low carbon energies is
has to be taken into account I think
this is we'll make a huge contribution
um I wrote it down somewhere
um
14 and a half thousand households
you couldn't feed 14 and a half thousand
households on that amount of land but
you could keep their lights on
um so decisions have to be made in that
context too and not only keep them on
but keep them on without burning fossil
fuels okay there will be some carbon
footprint from putting the things in
um in terms of
it's it's a temporary
installation though
I probably won't see it taken away
should it be put there but
the
recycling of the solar cells there this
is improving all the time though now
plants being built that will improve
that will recycle 90 percent of the
solar cells
um I think they what the proposed
landscape mitigation the trees the
extras the gaps being filled
will produce light
the possibilities of wildlife corridors
it could be improved
um
and and that's where I am with it
skylarks I think are a funny bird they
like a wide open space wherever it is
you can't predict whether they'll come
back to a particular field or
or um
they're not they're not a creature of
habit like um swallows where they'll
come back year after year to the same
nests
um but nevertheless land is being put
aside for them
I I think it is
of its nature are well thought through
proposal
um
it will have a huge impact it will ever
change
um
but
it it it is in a an appropriate site
when you regard the the access to the
sub station the existing grid connection
um
there will be disruption on Thailand but
other for a year there'll be disruption
and again that's going to be medicated
with further passing points and and
carefully managed and we can put that
into the reserve matters the
construction management program
I'm a little bit concerned about the um
the number of surveillance cameras I
think that they
cameras whichever way the point you see
them that psychologically the the
negative
and the
I think we we could perhaps look at some
additional screening around the um
the inverters the containers these sort
of rectangles that are going to be
dotted about I think perhaps they need
some additional
screen interview to sort of make them
disappear again from the site I mean
huge buildings like um
um not unit one the warehousing in the
distance which you could see
that thank you
um you know that there's a huge huge
buildings but in fact the sort of um
they do disappear into the landscape at
the distance so
I'm not 100 comfortable with but I think
I think it is of its nature a good
proposal
thank you uh councilor Penny did you
want to come in again
yeah I wanted to uh
second second your your comments to uh
begin with because I've I felt exactly
the same way
on just about everything you've said um
I just wanted to draw attention to the
existence of a report which is the which
which would biodiversity report for best
best practice for solar Farms which I
think recommends a six meter
Corridor for planting to create Wildlife
corridors but it also also includes a
variety of different habitats with ponds
and other
air areas around the site as well as
planting
uh diff different types of glasses
grasses and wildflowers so it is it
would be possible to create a very
diverse area around there
and modern modern farming itself
consists of a lot of monoculture so you
look at looking at those fields that
we've seen today you can imagine that
that uh a quarter of those will be
planted up with wheat and another
quarter with barley all in Big Blocks
so
in of itself modern farming is also
quite Industrial
and a large areas of solar panels are
clearly very industrial and man-made but
they're again they're just big blocks of
things
and in the distance as has been pointed
out you can see big blocks of
buildings like Port one
the density of some of the pylons could
be considered another block a massive
in in industrial monoculture
so
the landscape effects are not
particularly natural in that
area certain certainly looking towards
the West I think it's to to the east I
think the views to the West were a lot
a lot more natural
and the size of it is
stunning I'm quite um
do they need to be that big
thank you uh councilor I'll do counselor
okay first because she hasn't said
anything yet and I'll come back to you
Council
thank you
um yeah like everybody else I'm really
really tall
um we know we desperately need more
Renewable Power solar energy as fast as
we can possibly build it but it's got to
be in the right places
um I mean it's ironic that taking land
out of agricultural production can make
it much more biodiverse as a as a
colleagues have said in terms of what's
actually growing there if it's
wildflowers yes it would be lovely if
people could enjoy them unfortunately
that's probably not going to be the case
on a solar farm but um pollinators will
still be able to enjoy them so
there is that benefit
um we need the energy
um
the scale
just seems enormous I mean I we all know
these things have to be economically
viable and generate an appropriate
return but
we did walk along tracks today where
even though we were showing with posts
that there were panels coming up to
within you know five meters 10 meters
I do question did they have to come
right up to the edges all the way along
those footpaths uh could you still have
an economically viable solar farm with
just you know leaving one panel off the
end of some of those rows would would it
make a economic huge impact on the
project but it might make quite a big
impact for the people who are living
there and walking along those paths
um so it did feel like every scrap of
land had had solar panels squeezed into
it um
so yeah I'm Echo everybody else's
comments would love to see a bit more
space a bit more Breathing Room a lot
more planting if it's if it is going to
go ahead um but yeah really really tall
uh thank you
um
I'll let Colleen I'll let Council lay go
next and then I'll come back to council
having them
thank you chair
um
like many members of the committee I'm
I'm also in two minds we definitely need
this type of energy
um the walk today was incredibly well
planned
um
but incredibly vast
um a very long walk and one can only
imagine the impact for local residents
uh in all directions development could
be seen and I have full sympathies with
local residents
um on the subject of planting I would
welcome any connectivity between copses
and spinnies in the form of
hedgerocorridors does the
improvements of species such as door
mice
footpath eight in particular
um
personally feel could look quite
impressive with planting to the South
Side
in terms of the comments made about
feeling enclosed I'd highlight them for
many months of the winter months trees
have a very different appearance
um
and as I suppose I would really give
full support to councilor Penny's
comments that um there are further
options for increasing biodiversity
and you know looking back at the plans I
would definitely welcome some
consideration for these but yeah a very
difficult one and definitely into Minds
thank you uh councilor headingham
[Music]
and I agree we need um we need green
energy but um but I just think it could
be pulled back from the quiet roads it
could be pulled back from the Rutter's
farm and the Cottages there it can be
pulled back from Copenhagen Cottage and
um so the place Thai view Cottage I
think that they're being greedy I think
they could pull back from there they
could pull back from the footpath that
we look look or we walked along and um I
think it's been done to like you say
with absolutely using every last square
inch frankly to put panels on and I
think there's lots of places where they
can pull back we say we don't want
planting to to come right up to the edge
of the footpath because then you know
what's the point of that when you can
only see two meters either side of you I
think it actual panels have pulled back
the planting could be you know further
away to still give you a bit of space
when you're walking down there and I
think this could be vastly improved and
I think we've sent other um applications
back to have another thought you know to
think again and to reduce you know
frankly the the footprint of the solar
panels you know my own feeling is that
lots of things are meant to be temporary
like the Millennium Dome and a lot of
these um
prefabs after the war that were just
meant to sort of last for sort of 10
years and a lot of them are still being
used 50 years later and and so I worry
that after 35 years that this site will
still be you know like I said I
absolutely probably won't be here but
but I worry that this will continue to
be a solar farm you know for long after
we plan it to be but I can't think
that's probably not the Forum to get
into that right now
just if I may yep that um that they take
this away and sharpen their pencils a
bit
a legal term
um so so you are proposing
um that we defer it
um and what what do you want what what
what is going to be looked into as part
of the deferral I think I think we
probably just need to clarify that
rather than sharpen the pencils
reducing the area of um
reducing the area basically I think that
the triangle like um James said whether
Rutter's Cottages are could go I think
it could be pulled back from The Quiet
Road I think can be pulled back from the
footpath ground um Copenhagen Cottage
and Thai view Cottage that's my main
things but I I think yeah pull back from
the footpath and so then like I say we
can think about the planting rather than
having it right on the edge in little
teeny tiny little tracks that you know
people have to go around the edge of
that's my first thinking but obviously
I'm open to lots of other you know
people's ideas
so I think we need a seconder for that
um can't throw can you're happy to
second
cancel
well I was I was I was going to comment
on that I think the the developer had
already
agreed a willingness to um allow for for
more planting
um does it need to be deferred to
another meeting to allow that to happen
well I I was going to ask a similar
question because I've already queried
the fact that on the picture on the
diagrams it looks like the solar panels
go right to the edges and yet well what
we saw today was that they don't go
right to the edges so is there any scope
for
for that without it being deferred or or
not
big area of land so what you're seeing
on the planet look might look quite
narrow is perhaps bigger than one might
necessarily envisage it
um I think in terms of the landscaping
and the width if you have already got a
setback
the opportunity for landscaping can be
dealt with by condition I'd be very
happy to see that that's one of the
conditions bronze proposed so we could
look to have wider landscape and do that
by condition if however I think cancer
hadium suggested you want to sweep some
of the solar panels back
I think we would need to defer in order
to do that and conscious of what we have
done previously if the members were
minded to go that way I think we might
perhaps need 10 minutes just checking
with a developer that if they actually
want us to determine the application in
front of us which we really ought to do
that it would be prudent to check that
and that they are open to making those
amendments rather than we defer they
they haven't got any options in front of
them and um we come back and we haven't
negotiated anything in any case does
that help yeah and I think can we just
clarify that the the bit of
a lot less so I think you you also I
think you were also talking about that
that bit of uh where we first access the
site just north of Rutter's Cottages I
think you were talking about actually
not having that little piece it's not
just and that isn't just sweeping it
away you know flower Meadows ponds
hardingham were you going to contribute
to this debate yes
um
if we can
um condition
um for greater set batch particularly
for the track the access track to
Copenhagen Cottage I feel it would be a
responsible office to to actually try to
make a decision today
um I would like to suggest that one of
the conditions we might impose would be
that any planting took place in the
first available planting season namely
this winter
which may well precede development so as
to give it the best possible advantage
of getting ahead of of the insulation of
the panels
but I feel we ought to take a decision
today
and to maximize the opportunity as
councilor penny has said for joined up
Landscape features that landscape is
remarkably Barren it doesn't remotely
resemble the Suffolk I used to cycle
around as a boy in the 1960s
with five ten acre Fields where where a
10 acre a 20 acre field was an absolute
awesome site
so it wouldn't hurt at all to increase
the amount of hedge lines and and tree
lines in that landscape tool and it
could be made a lot more interesting
so that's that's where I stand thank you
thank you for that because I I too feel
that that that I think I feel that we
should make a decision today uh and and
if we if we're able to do so
um uh and and try and increase that uh
uh buffer that planting
um and as councilor Penny suggested
maybe put a bit of variety in some ponds
or whatever in into any of the wider
bits to to increase that
um I I I think I would prefer to go uh
make a decision about that today I
understand where councilor headings
coming from in removing that bit just
north of Russ's Cottage
um and I guess that's what we're we need
to decide we've we've got the proposal
for a deferral
um uh to go away and maybe remove that
bit and bring everything else back from
all the paths
um so it it I presume we've got a
proposal and a seconder for that so we
have to go through with a vote on that
yes so the situation at the moment
because
we would need to take that boat
and see the outcome unless that vote
that proposal was withdrawn for any
reason
uh but uh so given that we have that
proposal for a deferral would you like
five minutes with the applicant
um is I think that's what you were
saying yeah that was what I was just if
we've got a proposal
we would like to do then I think we need
to do that the opportunity that if
they're happy
then we can take that away if they're
not and we need to consider where we
take
and do that today rather than have to
come back again if that's right
so um did anyone else got anything to
say now and then we'll we'll maybe give
the officers um five minutes or ten
minutes to discuss with the applicant
does anyone want to make any comments
now so um if we take a break
um it's ten past seven so if we can be
back it is 10 5 10 minutes yeah
yeah Council holding them sorry uh I was
just wondering whether it would be a
possibility to take a kind of General
sounding of the members at this stage
full proceeding to that we have a
proposal which has a second so we have
to to cut that has to go through a
formal vote I think
um so um can we say we're back here at
20 past
um
we'll go as quickly as we can yeah thank
you
uh thank you and welcome back
um so do we just need to go to Gemma uh
for a little update thank you yeah thank
you chair so uh thank you members for
that uh brief pause just so we had a
conversation because what you want to do
is to say we could do something take it
away and then come back when there's no
options to so the conversation is that
there isn't the
activity on their side to
wholesale shop areas away bring it in
but what they can do is take out a row
of panels maybe two in certain places
like rapid cottages and the other
um areas that have been mentioned
so that is a potential so it would widen
the Landscaping
um and noting that we have currently got
a delegation to the chief planning
officer to sort out the Skylark
um mitigation whether the delegating
authority to the chief planning officer
that we could review and amend the
location of the panels with regard to
those particular places
um to include enhanced Landscaping
um there'd also been a mention of
getting a permissive path through those
so again that could be something that is
agreed how that might come into play
would it be secured but it would be
options and availabilities that that
would enable us to
prune in places around the edges
increase it whether that is enough is up
to members to consider but that's the
proposal that we we could take away but
you have got options before you and
obviously we have got a proposal so that
that would be if if we have a proposal
to defer it
um but the applicant is unlikely to come
back with anything that matches the
getting rid of the other bits so
um we currently have that proposal on
the table
um
if that doesn't go through we we do then
have the option of adding some extra
conditions and maybe having a different
proposal so uh
so what you're saying is they'll do a
little bit but not as much as I was
talking about so shall I withdraw my
thing and then we just carry on
discussing what it's up to you that you
you can withdraw it yeah there's no
point if they're saying we can do a
little but not much then I may as well
yeah but withdraw my um whatever
proposal and your second uh
um yeah
you carry on discussing it and and I
think I don't like it
um you know I'm happy to go for refusal
oh that means that proposal is no longer
no no longer there so um do we have any
other proposals
um that might want to come forward or
does anyone else want to make any uh
further contribution to debate
councilor Penny I feel I'm lacking a bit
of clap clap Clarity on what
specifically
um there is room for maneuver on uh
is it
was it as Lavinia was suggesting it
could
the boundaries could be set back a bit
and then planting begin of a substantial
nature
and a biodiverse environment or it
depends couldn't be removed yeah well so
it depends how you Define substantial
what we're saying is there's the the
corner
for example that I think councilor
having them was just in cut off the corn
and do away with uh what our applicant
is saying is that that is not certain
they could do what they could do is take
off a row maybe two panels to increase
the gap between the panels of Rutter's
Cottage and that they could increase and
that is to be agreed anyway the
Landscaping scheme
around the boundaries and through the
site so that we could get those
biodiversity gains and I know that we
have got a condition a couple of
conditions about biodiversity that would
also bring that together so it doesn't
go as far as
sing into the site but it would just
increase the distances but particularly
to the neighboring properties that were
mentioned so that was Rutter's Cottages
The Quiet Lane footpath Copenhagen
Cottage and Thai view Cottage so the
particular ones I've noted but if
members wanted to do something slightly
different we can that
Council War boys
uh thank you yes
um I think what a response I think
is very important in these
compromises if you like about landscape
that the parish council actually really
involved in their advice and suggestions
are listened to I think
um
we haven't mentioned the color of the
inverters yet so I think that needs to
be in there somewhere
um
it's um I think we have a responsibility
to come to a decision tonight there's
two things pressing
On My Mind One is the the context the
Precedence set by previous decisions in
the planning inspectorate about solar
Farms are now
difficult it is to find
material reasons for refusing them
and I do think
I this is my personal opinion but I do
think getting the best possible deal for
the communities in term of
of mitigating the impact is is
the most important and the best we can
actually do in the these circumstances
um we do have a responsibility and this
is is part of um
are
policy to support
rural Industries agricultural is a very
significant
rural industry and this isn't the first
time we've heard the argument in order
to make a farming business viable
you solar Farms provides a
a regular income stream if you'd like
that supports that viability and
in fact actually probably enhances the
business overall so I think that is a
responsibility we have
two in in order so
I I find the um
the conditions the applying officers I
find them acceptable so I think I've put
forward a proposal
to accept this
uh planning application
thank you
do we have a second for the proposal
cancer hardingham
I'm prepared to Second it on condition
that we stipulate
some of the limits of the solar farmer
are drawn back where they have most
impact on
people who live nearby that the parish
council and the residents consulted on
the type of planting that they feel
would enhance the site or mitigate as
far as possible the negative
consequences
and that the planting should take place
this coming winter if at all possible
and of course the usual things about
planting being replaced if if it should
fail
adequate precaution being taken for
watering in case of drought
thank you are you are you happy with
those addition cancer War boys
yeah
and can I just add that that I I hope
that in this discussion we've included
all of the proposed
planting Landscaping whatever you want
to call it to try and get it as
biodiverse as possible because we've had
some good suggestions from councilor
Penny about putting some water features
and and getting as wide of variety as
possible so does that all is that all
encompassing in that condition about
about the planting and they set back
from the pulse and the domestic
properties
yesterday I think so we've got a variety
of biodiversity conditions
um we've already had some ecological
surveys and that the development has got
to comply with those so we have done one
part obviously we've got skylarks to
follow which would be a subject to
agreement with our ecologist and in
terms of the landscape planting that
would be part of that biodiversity
package altogether
um would it help if I run through what
what I've got to make sure I've covered
everything and and we've also discussed
having the parish council involved in
discussing what gets planted
and do they also need to have to be make
sure that they um are fully on board
with whatever the construction
management plan is can they also be
consulted on that
at that point and then I think I've got
it before that's right with the proposal
everybody
so that was the construction traffic
management plan
so my suggestions at the moment chair I
hope for this covers everything is that
we are in one place uh sorry my computer
skipped
is that we are going to delegate
authority to the chief planning officer
to review and amend the location of
panels with regards to Rutter's Cottage
The Quiet Lane and footpaths
Copenhagen cottages
and Thai view Cottage including enhanced
landscaping and permissive path
provision in consultation with the
parish council and neighboring residents
then as a recommendation on pages 18 and
19 of the late papers with additional
conditions to agree the color and
Landscape screening of inverters
to undertake the construction traffic
management plan in consultation with the
parish council
sorry and then amend condition 17 which
is currently the landscape planting
scheme to include Advanced planting
prior to commencement of development to
be agreed so the timing of that
essentially can be agreed but that we're
requesting it in advance it's difficult
to say this winter next winter without
knowing when they start but by agreeing
that it gives us the opportunity to do
so I hope that covers everything Joe
do you think uh we've got everything
encapsulated there
accessible boys
I think we can now um go to the vote uh
with area probably manager has already
read it out so I don't think she needs
to read it out again
um and our governance officer will
conduct the electronic vote now I'll
cancel the war boys of council lay on
the system yet yes they can
count right so everyone else couldn't do
it electronically yeah yeah so members
that vote is um in progress it has been
updated to reflect what Gemma has read
out
Council of War boys
thank you
yes thank you members chair that is six
votes for and one against
now um carried
um so uh that application has now been
approved with all those conditions
um and we don't have any further cases
to discuss item number eight on the
agenda is about future site inspections
um do we have any more requests for site
inspections no received here thank you
so I can now formally close the meeting
at 1933. thank you very much